[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur
france 3 la chaîne de la proximité des
élections municipales pour notre grande
soirée de débat du mercredi des débats à
une heure de grande écoute pour tout
savoir et pour faire votre choix avant
la commune de sens dans une petite
cinquantaine de minutes place à notre
premier débat de la soirée avec dijon la
capitale régionale
un débat que j'ai le plaisir d'animer
avec stefan paris de france bleu
bourgogne bonsoir bonsoir lilian bonsoir
à tous nous sommes donc à dijon ce soir
dijon et ses 160 mille habitants ville
qui gagne des habitants dijon ville
d'histoire avec la longue lignée des
ducs de bourgogne dijon au capital de la
gastronomie avec sa future cité
internationale qui doit voir le jour fin
2021 politiquement historiquement dijon
ville de droite est dirigé depuis 2001
par la gauche et le socialiste françois
rebsamen est avec nous sur ce plateau
six têtes de listes bonsoir françois
rebsamen
bonsoir vous êtes le maire ps de dijon
depuis 2001 est donc candidat pour un
quatrième mandat
je suis ps c'est à dire je suis
socialiste mais je suis le maire de
dijon
merci de la précision stéphanie modde
bonjour bonjour vous étiez allié avec
françois rebsamen il ya six ans vous
était adjointe dans la majorité vous
mener cette fois la liste europe
écologie les verts bonsoir sylvain
comparot non soir c'est vous que la
république en marche a choisi pour
porter ses couleurs à dijon même si vous
n'êtes pas membre du parti mais vous
aviez initié une démarche citoyenne
oui et de large rassemblement sur avec
lui dit pour dijon l'association
citoyenne que j'avais créé et une
affiche aux bonsoir vous êtes le
candidat de la droite et d'une partie du
centre c'est la première fois que vous
êtes candidat sur sur dijon et vous
menez la tête de liste des républicains
donc sur des jo damien quentin bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes tête de liste du
rassemblement national à dijon et enfin
arnaud granata mme bouffard vous êtes
tête de liste de la france insoumise et
du parti des ouvriers indépendant élégie
jaune et du parti de gauche dans le
cadre d'un rassemblement citoyen trois
autres candidats sont en lice pour un
total à dijon pour un total de neuf donc
bruno louy qui mène une liste écologiste
jean baptiste gavignet une liste
d'avocats pour protester contre la
réforme des retraites est claire rocher
pour lutte ouvrière nous les entendrons
un peu plus tard dans cette émission et
on commence par notre premier thème
stéphane oui le premier thème lilian que
nous avons intitulé dit
on ville attractive où dijon ville musée
tout le monde s'accorde à dire que dijon
est une destination touristique son
centre-ville classé zone touristique
internationale son musée des beaux-arts
reconnu comme l'un des plus beaux musées
de france
sa future cité de gastronomie de la
gastronomie je les dis internationale
est ce que tout cela suffit à attirer
des touristes et de nouveaux habitants
faut-il continuer à construire des
logements ou faire une pause comme le
suggèrent certains d'entre vous on va
vous entendre et avant de donner la
parole au maire sortant françois
rebsamen je veux tourner vers peut-être
son principal opposant au conseil
municipal emmanuel bichot
on va commencer avec vous est ce qu'on
en fait trop pour les touristes à dijon
et pas assez pour les habitants alors
moi je pense que dijon un potentiel
touristique qui est insuffisamment
exploité encore aujourd'hui même s'il ya
des progrès et tout le monde a intérêt à
jouer cette carte parce que c'est quand
même une partie de l'économie locale ce
sont des emplois bien évidemment il ne
faut pas tomber non plus dans la sur
exploitation touristique il faut il faut
être vigilant à cet écueil
mais je crois qu'on a encore beaucoup de
potentiel touristique c'est pour ça que
nous avons nous deux propositions la
première c'est d'ouvrir le palais des
ducs et des états aux dijonnais et aux
visiteurs extérieurs
aujourd'hui malheureusement la
rénovation n'a porté que sur le musée
des beaux-arts
ce projet global a été oubliée alors
qu'il était dans les cartons il ya déjà
plus de 20 ans et nous voulons
absolument avoir ce produit phare en
fait ce qui manquait de dijon
aujourd'hui en termes touristiques et en
terme d'image c'est un produit phare ce
produit phare ce joyau nous l'avons sous
les yeux c'est le palais des ducs les
anodes bourgogne donc ouvrons nos
visiteurs nous aurons plus de 4 400
mille visiteurs par an rien que sur ce
rien que sur ce site on confierait que
le musée des beaux-arts en complément
c'est la compare aux
le sens de notre question c'était quand
on privilégie le tourisme est ce que on
n'oublie pas aussi un peu les dijonnais
leur vie quotidienne les autres
quartiers non et surtout pour revenir là
dessus les hôteliers ce qu'ils ont
besoin c'est d'avoir de l'attractivité
dans les zones dans les périodes de
l'année où on a un peu moins de clients
notamment en hiver et donc je pense
qu'on exploite oms ou exploitent
l'unesco et le prix qu'on a eu au niveau
des climats et il faut qu'on utilise
peut-être pour créer un événement autour
de la saint vincent
ce qui va nous obliger à travailler avec
bonne parce que je crois et les
entreprises en ont besoin ça c'est pour
la partie attractivité il faut
absolument qu'on puisse réussir à faire
venir des talents et pour réussir à
faire venir des talents il va falloir
qu'on augmente la zone de chalandise
pour qu'on ait un emploi pour monsieur
et pour madame monsieur monsieur madame
madame en tout cas pour cela il faut que
l'on joue en meute et en meute c'est le
triangle doré dijon beaune dole et voyez
en termes de tourisme
ça permettra de faire travailler les
deux cités de la gastronomie et du vin
ensemble et c'est ensemble qu'on pourra
développer dijon françois rebsamen en
posant la question de cette manière là
pour tout vous dire on pensait que
certains trouvent vrai la ville trop
touristique et pas assez tourné vers les
dijonnais elle est passée touristique
alors d'après d'après certains c'est ce
que vous pensez vous il faut leur
équilibre et autrement
dijon en 20 ans s'est profondément
transformé c'est une ville aujourd'hui
qui est une capitale régionale qui
compte 160 mille habitants et c'est une
ville d'art et d'histoire
elle est labellisée d'ailleurs ville
d'art et d'histoire ces 100 hectares de
secteurs sauvegardés sont classés au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco est donc
cette ville a tous les atouts pour être
une ville active attractive et elle
l'est d'ailleurs puisque ne serait-ce
que le plus beau musée de province des
beaux-arts de france il est à dijon et
ils attirent quatre cent cinquante mille
visiteurs navid musée c'est laissez-moi
économique sans doute les six mois
terminés je suis pas fini
et donc il attire ce musée 450 mille
visiteurs dans le palais des ducs parce
que c'est la moitié du palais des ducs
dijon c'est aussi une ville de tourisme
et d'affaires très important parce que à
dijon il y à un million de nuitées par
an a dijon il y a en moyenne à peu près
3 millions 300 mille touristes et pour
vous montrer que c'est une ville
dynamique et kehl
il y a huit projets de construction
d'hôtels sur 10 jan on voit bien que
dijon se développe en plus des gens
c'est aussi non son centre ville une
ville de commerce et c'est une ville où
les commerces se créent de nouveaux
commerces apparaissent une vingtaine de
commerces nouveaux sont apparus au cours
du dernier semestre 2010 9 et le taux de
vacance des commerces au centre ville
est un des plus bas de france je suis
content de le dire avec 6,3 pour cent de
taux de vacance ce qui paraît ce qui
correspond à peu près à la rotation des
commerces et puis c'est une ville où il
ya beaucoup de monde au centre ville
cent soixante mille piétons vous
imaginez 160000 piétons si on prend le
haut de la rue de la liberté
80000 rue des godrans 70000 rue piron
70000 rudoyé le centre-ville vie et vit
bien et il fait vivre son commerce et
puis je vous empêcher de partir je vais
terminer après je vous laisserais bien
sûr reprendre le fil de votre discussion
mais je voudrais dire ça chante je
voudrais ajouter quelque chose parce que
tout ça c'est dans une métropole qui
elle aussi est à taille humaine
l'avenir est aux métropoles à taille
humaine c'est une métropole de 260 mille
habitants qui a créé quatre mille
emplois voyez je vais y répondent
économiquement qui a créé 4000 emplois
depuis 2014 qui compte aujourd'hui 94
mille emplois et qui attire les
entreprises qui un taux de chômage
extrêmement bas de 6 19% donc à la
question que vous posez je vous réponds
dijon est une belle ville économiquement
attractive et non pas une ville musée
mais une ville où il ya le plus beau
musée de france pour rebondir à ce que
vous dites françois rebsamen stéphanie
modde est ce que on attire de nouveaux
habitants des touristes uniquement par
son centre-ville où est-ce qu'on peut
aussi développer et quartiers à dijon
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est ce qu'une ville rayonne
uniquement par son centre-ville ces
commerces et musées est ce qu'on peut
faire autre chose une ville rayonne par
effectivement déjà son centre ville donc
nous avons un très beau centre ville et
nous pensons vraiment qu'il faut pour
que tous les dijonnais tous les
métropolitains tous les dorians si aulas
puisse en profiter
donc on est effectivement pour un
tourisme nous on est sur un tourisme
plus solidaire aussi un tourisme très
responsable à son c'est dans nos modes
de vie nos modes de consommation on
arrive à cela on va bien aussi la
fragilité de nos économies
dès qu'il ya quelque chose qui se passe
il faut aussi qu'on a tourisme à la fois
qu'ils viennent de loin mais aussi un
tourisme plus local sur un tourisme donc
plus durable avec une économie qui dit
économie de l'avenir sera sur un
tourisme justement plus responsable donc
avec une attractivité
bien évidemment de son centre ville un
centre vite qu'on fait + végétalisée
aussi pour justement qu'on le regarde de
près le cadre de view et puis donc
commerce de proximité aussi ce sont des
services de proximité et il faut
effectivement que tous les dix jeunesse
dijonnaise puisse continuer donc
effectivement on a un centre ville qu'il
faut continuer à vendre nos commerces de
proximité encourager le commerce de
proximité parce que c'est un service
rendu à tous et toutes dans le haut fond
de nos questions il y avait aussi ce que
certains d'entre vous reproche à la
dimension urbaine et construction de
dijon avec avec un centre-ville ancien
et puis d'autres choses qu'on fait
autour en ukraine à tam quelle est votre
position là dessus
à écouter quand nous on va à la
rencontre des habitants la fontaine
d'ouche au brésil qui subissent un
certain nombre de disparités vis-à-vis
de la politique du centre-ville ils nous
disent qu'ils se sentent abandonnés et
que la politique était faite
exclusivement pour le centre ville et
donc à un moment donné il s'agit aussi
de rendre le territoire attractif parce
que vous avez la combe à la serpent
enfin la fontaine d'ouche est un
magnifique quartier et moi je suis allé
au grésy très récemment la tour boutaric
à l'appel des habitants et on a constaté
dans du logement social qu'il y avait
des conditions de vie qui était terrible
malgré la dignité la solidarité des
habitants et à un moment donné je crois
que pour développer du commerce de
proximité
il est aussi nécessaire que
l'attractivité se fasse dans des
quartiers
j'avais pas dire périphériques mais
autre que le centre-ville moi j'ai pris
les connaissances de certaines personnes
qui décident de quitter l'ingénierie de
projets pour monter des sociétés
coopératives d'intérêt collectif afin de
développer des épiceries pour faire
travailler des maraîchers locaux afin de
faire du commerce de proximité bio local
et zéro déchet donc moi je pense que
c'est vraiment dans ce contexte là d'un
tourisme socialement écologiquement
responsable parce qu'il s'agit pas tout
le temps de faire le des ménages grand
déménagement du même temps le fort de
mon avis ça il va quand même y avoir des
milliers de touristes qui viennent
du jeu qui viennent d'italie nine donc
et de france et de france parce
qu'effectivement il ya aussi à une
attractivité de dijon sur sur la
question voilà effectivement du tourisme
national
mais il s'agit il s'agit aussi le
pouvoir développer des quartiers qui ne
sont pas exclusivement au centre ville
pour développer du commerce de proximité
et l'attractivité des territoires
alors comment on développe ses quartiers
je me tourne vers vos dania quentin vous
souhaitez par exemple interdire la
construction
je les ai vus sur les sur des terres
agricoles par rapport à l'éco quartier
des lentillères je crois qu'au mans
développe ses quartiers comment rentrer
active ces quartiers si on ne construit
pas alors pour revenir sur votre
question ville un musée ou ville
attractive voilà je ne suis pas qu'un
opposant je sais aussi à reconnaître les
grands projets les grands travaux menés
pour notre ville nota et notre métropole
notamment le zénith la piscine et musée
des beaux-arts
on est tous d'accord pour dire que c'est
une magnifique réussite mais derrière
derrière ce cet inventaire se cache
aussi à un bilan catastrophique vous
l'avais dit en matière d'urbanisme
totalement délirant une explosion de la
sécurité j'y reviendrai et un abandon du
centre ville
quand vous êtes contre la construction à
outrance on arrête de construire sur
dijon alors je suis plutôt oui pour
rénover déjà l'existant j'en ai déjà
parlé pour le centre ville moi je pense
que pour qu'il soit attractif il faut
donner envie aux gens d'y venir aux
personnes d'y passer du temps de
consommer et ça passe déjà tout d'abord
par le stationnement s'y rendre
facilement le style le stationnement
vous connaissez mes propositions c'est
la première heure gratuite en semaine et
le samedi gratuits
les premiers mercredis des sols de la
voiture c'est pas tellement dans le sens
de l'histoire en ce moment en terme
environnemental transition bien sûr mais
on va pas distribuer le mauvais points à
la mère de famille inquiète il sa
voiture le mercredi après midi pour
emmener le premier au rugby la petite à
la danse à et faire des courses à un
moment donné on obligé aussi en famille
bien sûr être est aussi l'homme et on
n'est pas là pour distribuer le mauvais
point pour l'automobiliste est bon point
pour la personne qui fait du vélo je
suis pour que tous les modèles de
transport coexistent au centre-ville
jour revenir et s'aligne aussi par
terminer je voulais vous un centre ville
attractif ce sont nos commerces une
offre de commerce diversifié et de
qualité
je pense aussi qu'on arrivait au maximum
de ce qu'on pouvait faire sur la
piétonnisation
on l'a vu rue charrue et rue piron les
fonds de commerce
il y en a beaucoup à vendre et il ya eu
une forte rotation donc vous voulez
remettre en circulation les rues charrue
et les rues pire on on a aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on arrivait au maximum de la
piétonnisation plus personne plus de
kétou nisation pour moi ou avec un
moratoire avec en concertation avec les
commerçants bien sûr pour avancer sur
juste parce que vous vouliez vous lire
moi j'avais envie de vous dire dans le
clan y avait des grues dans une idylle
on disait que la ville est en bonne
santé et j'ai l'impression que ce n'est
pas forcé c'est plus forcément ce que ce
qu'on dit aujourd'hui moi je voulais
revenir sur la question des
constructions les constructions
nouvelles les constructions de le jour
aujourd'hui effectivement là la
stratégie de la municipalité sortante et
la métropole c'est de dire il faut
construire le plus possible de logement
neuf à dix jours nous nous considérons
qu'il faut un équilibre entre l'emploi
et malheureusement l'emploi si on prend
les dix dernières années stagne entre
2009 et 2019
il a exactement le même nombre d'emplois
salariés après une baisse et une légère
remontée années qu'il montre l'emploi un
équilibre entre la qualité du cadre de
vie et un équilibre bien sûr entre les
les constructions et donc si on
déstabilise cet équilibre on va vers de
grands désordres et regardez ce qui
s'est passé chez nous on a construit à
tout va on est monté à 22 milles
habitants et maintenant chenôve est à
moins de quatorze mille habitants
donc ce qu'en fait effectivement pour
rejoindre pour pour répondre à votre
question il ya sept centre-ville qui est
extraordinaire sati cette histoire ce
patrimoine est encore une fois le palais
des ducs et d état et notre notre notre
produit phare qu'il faut mettre en avant
mais il y a également le risque que l'an
le règle que la ville soit défigurée par
des constructions anarchiques et
intempestives tel qu on les constate
aujourd'hui et nous nous voulons freiner
ce rythme de construction et l'encadrer
respecter sur le logement pour boucler
la dessus stéphanie modde va comparer
ensuite nous devons vraiment rentré dans
la transition écologique
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose
un équilibre à trouver actuellement
entre la densification de la ville que
nous avons soutenu pour autant il faut
aussi un urbanisme maîtrisé
donc effectivement c'est pour pouvoir
avoir une vie
qui se densifie en ayant des espaces de
respiration pour revenir aussi
effectivement le commerce de
centre-ville cette importante par contre
dans tous les quartiers il faut bien
évidemment des équipements de proximité
des commerces de proximité pour que
chacun puisse y vivre correctement dans
les quartiers dans lesquels ils vivent
voilà donc ça c'est un bel équilibre que
nous que nous souhaitons donc des
espaces de respiration dans tous les
projets de construction
peut-être ralentir effectivement voir
déjà remplir les appartements faire de
la construction de qualité de la qualité
architecturale mais en tout cas nous
avons aussi cette densification pour
éviter l'étalement urbain et puis bien
évidemment les l'idée de remettre de la
voiture au centre-ville c'est une
aberration expulsions très important
d'avoir des matériaux qu'ils soient
écologiquement responsable parce que le
tas de béton c'est extrêmement
consommateurs d'eau et donc il ya des
alternatives que nous on a soutenu
choses qui existent pour faire autre
chose que du béton dans deux éléments
d'une part on parle beaucoup de
centre-ville mais dijon ça se résume pas
un centre-ville il ya neuf quartiers à
dijon et moi j'aime bien parler de la
politique dans neuf quartiers
donc pour les commerces il faut à la
fois pouvoir mettre en place des
boutiques éphémères dans l'ensemble des
huit autres quartiers parce que sur le
centre-ville
je suis assez d'accord il n'y a pas de
problème on n'est pas arrivé à une zone
on a des boutiques fermées et donc c'est
pas là où il ya un problème
le problème c'est le commerce de
proximité dans les quartiers il faut
pouvoir le développer à la fois par un
stationnement gratuit
trente minutes pour pouvoir aller
chercher sa baguette de pain pour aller
chercher ces fleurs 30 minutes c'est
jouable
une heure c'est beaucoup trop et puis
ensuite ensuite ensuite sur les
commerces
c'est un élément mais il faut ensuite
revoir les quartiers sur l'ensemble et
sur l'ensemble il ya une bétonisation
qui a été mis en place depuis dix ans
depuis l'ancien plan local d'urbanisme
c'est d'ailleurs bien pour ça que j'ai
jamais été pour revoir de fond en comble
nouveau puisque le nouveau et meilleur
mais le résultat de ce qu'on a en termes
de bétonisation aujourd'hui à dijon
c'est bien le résultat de la majorité
sortante à la fois europe ecologie les
verts et le maire sortant et je suis
pour ma part plus pour une rénovation à
la fois qualitative et durable on va
laisser répondre françois rebsamen
puisque les candidats les jeunes qui
sont ici s'oppose à la construction vous
vous dites par contre il faut continuer
à construire on
non dit me loger panique il fallait pas
de la densification
mais il faut la maîtriser 110 mille
logements même histoire half a men
l'annoncé dix mille logements d'ici 2030
sur sur dijon on a vraiment besoin de
ces 10000 7500 demande de logements qui
sont pas satisfaites et 7000 c'est qu'on
s'est logiquement pas et quand et
pourquoi c'est pas vrai nous n'avons
logement mais c'est le turnover non sur
94 milles mais faudra vous renseigner
sur 94 milles c'est le turnover normal
et donc on a un peu de logements en
cours sur des gens peu logements vacants
sur des gens et on à 7500 demande de
logements non satisfaite et il a fallu
construire pour d'abord remplir les
objectifs que la loi nous fixait puisque
nous n'avions pas 20 % de logements
locatifs à loyer modéré nous les avons
maintenant à l'époque madame duflot
voulez qu'on aille jusqu'à 25 jan aps le
rappelle quand ma fille l'élan qu'elle
proposait pas d'arrêter ou de stopper la
construction elle proposait d'aller plus
avant et elle avait raison
parce que quand on construit on permet
d'avoir dévoyé des loyers qui sont pas
trop élevés et c'est pour cela que à
dijon on a plus d'habitants parce que
les habitants ne fuit plus la ville
centre c'est la seule ville centre de
tout le grand est qui gagnent des
habitants et donc je voudrais dire à
ceux qui disent qu'on embête own ceux
des mots qui sont pas très bon parce
qu'il ya onze mille emplois qui
dépendent du secteur du logement en écho
les six mois terminés
onze mille emplois qui dépendent du
secteur du logement et des travaux
publics c'est donc très important et
dans le nouveau p lus hd c'est à dire
plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal
pour la première fois qui a été validé
par 22 maires sur 23
je le rappelle quand même c'est pas rien
et bien il y a sur des gens il ya
combien de d'hectares qu'ils vont être
limités à sept mètres de hauteur de
construction est ce que quelqu'un peut
me répondre
a dijon il ya 2200 hectares urbanisées
et il y en aura vous m'entendez daniel
racette cents soit 33% où on ne pourra
pas construire à plus de 7 mètres de
hauteur
c'est ça un urbanisme maîtrisé alors on
va alors je vous propose d'avancer un
petit peu sinon on reste sur le logement
sur le logement façon alors en continu
non mais c'est très important on
viendrait pas
c'est très important parce que c'est le
sujet majeur de cette élection
en particulier le nouveau bond
invitant le nouveau plan local
d'urbanisme
maintenant c'est ce qui intéresse le
plus les dijonnais le nouveau ensemble
dans le nouveau plan local d'urbanisme
il prévoit vous l'avez dit dix mille
logements sur 2020 2030 c'est à dire
mille par an le au maximum convient de
faire en 2018 on arrive à 700 logements
neufs livrés donc en fait c'est une
accélération par rapport à ce qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui une accélération de
50% de ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
pendant dix ans avec chaque dix jeunes
essayent de n'ose imaginer ça fait pas
ce à quoi par voie orale à quoi va
ressembler sa ville basse à dans dix ans
et c'est là on rejoint votre question
initiale sur l'attractivité de la ville
effectivement peut pas se contenter
d'avoir un secteur sauvegardé tout à
fait exceptionnel et puis deux et puis
de défigurer tout le reste tout le reste
on ta vie là bas si je voudrais revenir
sur les loges pour sa ville il faudra
aller dire adresse je voudrais revenir
sur les logements sociaux
nous considérons qu effectivement eu un
énorme rattrapage puisque on a doublé le
parc de logements sociaux qui est passé
est passé de 9000 à un peu plus de 17000
aujourd'hui nous considérons qu'il faut
faire une pause se stabiliser au 20 %
demandés par la loi et s'occuper de bien
gérer le parc social existant un
modernisme dame sur le logement social
je vouvoyais ne pas être d'accord
non mais il faut être bien gérer parce
qu'effectivement c'était sur le nombre
le fait d'arrêter de construire des
logements que femme et non mais nous
comptons sidère c'est qu'à un moment
donné
le plan de rénovation du bâti il doit
être il est ambitieux moi j'ai travaillé
un petit peu en franche comté
ils ont des dispositifs régionaux qui
s'appelle effilogis les municipalités
peuvent travailler avec ça donc je pense
qu'il ya déjà des partenariats créés
avec la région afin de mettre en place
un plan de rénovation du bâti existant
qui soit ambitieux au delà à construire
des nouveaux logements au-delà de ça
quand il ya la construction neuve
nous on pense qu'il faut aller au-delà
des 20% de logements sociaux sur la
construction des vendeurs on a parlé de
30 % de logements sociaux et très
sociaux mais il faut quand même que le
les permis construire qui soit délivré
par la mairie
au delà du pays lui reste laisse une
place très importante aux nouveaux
matériaux et à la nature et aux
conditions écologiques dans laquelle
c'est dans laquelle cesser ces
constructions sont réalisés parce qu'à
un moment donné on voit certains
quartiers où on manque de mixité sociale
et l'intérêt c'est de pouvoir dynamiser
aussi cette mixité sociale parce que en
fait ça fait baisser détention de dé
tous ensemble on avait prévu trois
chapitres mais avec le temps qui passe
voit la série mode
ça va être compliqué vous avez ouvert
sur un sujet qui est un sujet qu'on
entend beaucoup en ce moment quel sujet
de l'environnement des villes aussi face
au réchauffement et je moi je propose
qu'on avance sur ce sujet là aussi
on entend parfois dijon le problème des
arbres si être trop d'arbres n'y a pas
assez d'arbres est-ce qu'il faut
végétalisée une ville est ce que c'est
une bonne idée est ce que face au
réchauffement climatique c'est la
solution est ce qu'il ya plein d'autres
choses à faire est ce qu'une ville
ancienne elle est faite pour ça j'ouvre
on ouvre le débat
je vous voyais faire un geste damien
quentin là dessus alors nous
effectivement nous avons proposé de
végétaliser le centre ville mais sa
ville en globalité on n'a pas envie de
faire la course à celui qui va planter
le plus d'arbres sur les six dernières
années j'ai vu peu d'arbres plantés et
beaucoup de groupes poussé comme on en
parlait juste avant donc nous notre idée
c'est de planter six mille arbres sur la
ville avec la moitié d'arbres fruitiers
dans des parcs pour rendre bien sûr la
ville plus agréable des parcs existants
des réacteurs plus agréable plus verte
et créé des parcours végétalisée en
centre-ville pour donner envie aux
personnes d'aller rue piron rue charrue
à portée de la végétalisation je pense
de rup's et de re qui voudraient féminin
dans celui centre-ville oui le rue de la
liberté aussi manqué un peu de
végétalisation aussi bien bien entendu
sur l'environnement nous avons siens un
autre un autre cheval de bataille c'est
le localisme
pour nous c'est un scorer vraiment les
circuits courts dans les restaurants
scolaires
voilà j'ai entendu beaucoup fait
parlement européen ont signé tous
annoncent les traités de libre-échange
certaines options les raconter n'importe
quoi nous c'est du bon sens on préfère
acheter chez l'agriculteur à côté de
chez nous que de faire un constat mais
nouveau trio notamment à l'amérique du
sud
on changera containers de libre-échange
apporter des jeux pour justement qu'on
en fait traité de libre échange que nous
avons d'ailleurs adopté nous raconter
vraiment n'importe où via non mais bien
sûr sur la végétalisation
écoutez moi je suis déjà tout d'abord
mais vraiment contente que ce sujet de
l'environnement de la transition
écologique maintenant soit portée par
l'ensemble des partis politiques
ç'a vraiment c'est une grande nouveauté
bon je demande après avoir dans
certaines réalisations mais bon et vous
aider au pouvoir madame tout à fait
s'est il passé
si je peux parler merci encore en jeu
sur sur la végétalisation pour
écologique c'est la transition
écologique qui dit que de toute façon on
actuellement donc on a bien vu on a des
épisodes de canicule on a des épisodes
aussi depuis intense donc il va faire
nous adapter à ce changement climatique
donc la végétation c'est bien évidemment
important c'est des armes quand on peut
mettre des arts on a déjà beaucoup
d'armes hardyson sauf qu'ils sont
concentrés sur la partie ouest on a des
très belles coin on a des services des
espaces verts qui font beaucoup de bobos
travail donc là c'est comment
revégétaliser notamment le centre vie
mais également effectivement les
quartiers en construction parfois il
manque cruellement de végétalisation la
phase 1 d'éco quartier dit des
maraîchers en manque donc il faut qu'on
va vraiment commencer de laon relais ça
sert à quelque chose à sert à quelque
chose ça sert déjà à lutter contre la
pollution puisque les armes et toute la
végétation ça capte donc c'est la
captation du gaz à effet de serre
sercret des îlots de fraîcheur justement
pour dans les épaules des épisodes de
canicules qu'on puisse mieux respirer
salue donc contre la pollution de l'air
aussi donc c'est vraiment bien
évidemment et c'est du cadre de vie on
sait aussi que l'on vit mais dans un
environnement et c'est la biodiversité
parce qu'au-delà du dérèglement
climatique on a aussi le problème de la
perte de la biodiversité donc c'est
aussi recréer des trains vers quand nous
nous proposons et ça fait un moment
qu'on propose un chemin vert à travers
dijon donc voilà sylvain comparot les
lots de fraîcheur vous êtes pour aussi
c'est le vin comparé au crest cci aux
tricheurs dont parlait alors nous on
appelle ça des bulles de fraîcheur non
mais je veux juste revenir sur la
végétalisation des quartiers minéralisée
parce qu'il n'ya pas que le centre-ville
on parle beaucoup du centre-ville mais
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est toujours
l'ensemble de de dijon et sur cette
question c'est plus une question
climatologiques ou d'environnement c'est
une question de santé publique
il fait entre 5 et 8 degrés c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est des laboratoires 5
et 8 degrés d'écart la nuit l'été à
dijon entre les espaces minéralisée
comme le centre-ville où d'autres
quartiers minéralisée j'étais aux
grésillés une réunion publique
dernièrement on en a parlé
pour les nourrissons pour les personnes
âgées on doit traiter ce sujet le maire
doit protéger la ville et donc pour
cette question on trouvera les experts
on trouvera les chercheurs c'est aussi
notre manière de fond de faire
fonctionner la ville
la faire fonctionner en collaboration
avec ceux qui savent aujourd'hui le
politique c'est pas le sachant
il faut déminéralisée si je prie ce
thème à vis d habiliter le meilleur la
pression ce thème pour c'est assez
savoureux d'entendre ma voisine de
gauche qui est adjointe au cadre de vie
expliqué qu'il faut faire tout à fait
autrement que ce que fait la majorité
que ce que fait la majorité sortante
actuelle surtout après avoir voté avec
enthousiasme le plan local d'urbanisme
en décembre 2018 acheté en décembre 2018
vous avez voté avec enthousiasme le
projet qui a été soumis à la
consultation des habitants
mais empêcher le je suis ravi qu'on est
ici aujourd'hui à nos thèses le propose
le versement ben oui parce que sur les
rebelles abattus alors le sur le pea lui
nous avons été contre celui de 2010 mais
prédécesseur françois xavier dugourd et
nous avons combattu depuis trois ans le
projet qui vient d'être adoptée vous
m'autorisez vous dire que sortie du
logement tourner je voudrais revenir sur
la question des projets après d'autres
choses foule et désespère les espaces
verts les espaces verts en fait ils sont
dans l'est dans les jardins et quand on
détruit des quartiers pavillonnaires
aujourd'hui l'aspect de la particularité
de dijoux c'est qu'on apprend à protéger
monsieur le maire sortant parle de
d'avoir plafonné à 7 mètres dans
certains quartiers il plus les absents
de la vie mais vous n'avez vous ne vous
n'avez protéger nos biens
aucune rue aucun quartier pavillonnaire
n'est protégé à dijon ce qui est une
anomalie par rapport à toutes les
grandes villes françaises
il faut sanctuariser des rues et des
quartiers pavillonnaires pour conserver
cette trame verte de jardin qui est une
ville ce sont des immeubles et des
maisons
ce ne sont pas que des que des immeubles
à la fin voilà c'est ce que nous ont
invités dans dix ans ce sont 24 cas
temps de répondre que son bébé après
après on parle d'écologie urbaine
donc là il faut pas confondre je vais
parler d'arbres on pouvait parler plein
mais oui mais les arbres on n'est pas
dans la forme d'arbre on a planté 13
1500 arbres quand on a fait le tramway
si vous savez pas où sur les trames
vertes regardez pas ce sera un arbre
fermé donc 13500 a été planté et puis
2500 dans les cours d'école il faut
savoir de quoi on parle
mais c'est pas ça l'objet c'est pas la
course à l'arbre aujourd'hui il ya une
menace très profonde
c'est le dérèglement climatique et nous
devons prendre des mesures de grande
ampleur
et les villes ont un rôle à jouer en la
matière il s'agit pas de planter trois
arbres ou de végétaliser bien sûr tout
le monde va le faire nous aussi on va
mettre des fontaines au centre ville
pour que ça soit plus frais pour tout le
monde mais ce qu'il faut c'est prendre
des mesures radicales et qu'est ce qu'on
va faire on va arrêter d'augmenter notre
empreinte carbone à la ville de dijon
donc moins de voitures dans le
centre-ville ça c'est déjà fait vous
l'avez vu on va continuer avec la rue
monge très bientôt mais c'est pas ça
l'objet l'objet c'est de trouver
d'autres énergies des énergies fossiles
et donc nous avons trois grands projets
que je voudrais expliquer en 30 secondes
parce que vous avez rejoint j'ai pas le
plus 3 granger trois grands premièrement
on va couvrir l'ancienne décharge de la
ville de dijon avec une centrale
photovoltaïque sa produira d'électricité
con affectera pour le tramway
deuxièmement on va faire la
méthanisation des boues issues de la
station d'épuration on produira du
méthane qu on introduira dans le réseau
de chaleur
troisièmement on va transformer notre
électricité produite par l'unité de
valorisation des déchets en hydrogène et
l'engagement que nous prenons
c'est d'être la première ville hydrogène
de france qu'on équipera nos bus à
l'hydrogène
on équipera nos bennes à ordures et à
l'hydrogène et l'hydrogène et bien c'est
plus de pollution
c'est de l'eau transformée bien
évidemment et c'est l'air pur à dijon et
c'est l'engagement que nous prenons ça
c'est lutter vraiment contre le
réchauffement et après c'est s'adapter
au réchauffement c'est pas la même chose
s'adapter c'est planter des arbres c'est
végétalisée rapport à pas contés ya 46
mille arbres à dijon il y en a
énormément partout que vous regardez
vous regarderez ce qu'ils étaient avant
la venue du drapeau puis vous verrez ce
qu'elle est devenue aujourd'hui si vous
voulez voir tout ça venait à mon meeting
demain soir vous verrez on produira des
bébelles veillée vidéo avec une réussite
au passage en guyane à au delà de ce qui
a été dit il ces familles de déchets ce
que vient de dire aux jeunes il y ait
plus de déchets hydrogène oui mais au
delà de ce qui a été dit c'est qu'à un
moment donné il faut lier la question
sociale la question écologique et la
question démocratique voit par exemple
que on continue à faire des profits avec
des multinationales sur la gestion de
l'eau alors qu'elles sont une ressource
qui va amener de plus en plus de
conflits et qu'on doit gérer vrai oui et
qu'on doit gérer cette ressource pour
passer une agriculture paysanne
biologique locale sortir du tout
pesticide puisqu'en plus l'eau est
d'assez mauvaise qualité puisque le
pesticide remonter au niveau qualité des
ces mois terminée le syrenor moi je vous
dis quand même mais où
mais oui oui la préfecture quoi donc
c'est ce que je disais il ya cette
manière de gérer la ressource qui doit
être écologiquement serez socialement
responsable donc arrêtez avec les
privatisations des biens communs c'est
gérer mieux cette ressource pour des
questions écologiques donc je disais
pour l'agriculture cissé public c'est
forcément mieux géré que si c'est arrivé
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que dans
une régie publique de l'eau
vous n'avez pas là et rodez paix qui a
indûment payées par les dijonnais 15% de
leur facture les bénéfices qui vont au
droit sièges soit logique mais bien sûr
qu'ici c'est une ressource
c'est une ressource qu'on doit gérer au
mieux donc la question écologique
c 'est les questions de transition c'est
gérer les ressources la gratuité des
transports c'est aussi faire reculer la
voiture s'est fait reculer les gaz et
bien vous nous traitez les thèmes qu'on
a peu de temps après c'est bien sûr mais
parce qu'à un moment donné il faut il
faut il faut il faut mettre en avant le
fait que des biens communs qui sont
essentiels à l'intérêt général à la vie
humaine ne doivent plus être géré par le
privé il faut sortir de ces logiques là
absolument il existe en france un
principe démocratique qui s'appelle la
délégation de service public mais il
existe aussi un principe démocratique
c'est que quand vous avez été élus en
2014 n'aviez pas mandat pour continuer à
prolonger avec suez vous l'avez jamie
dimon dans votre programme en 2014 un
trophée un moment donné donc à un moment
donné dijonnais ont le droit d'avoir un
débat démocratique sur le mode de
gestion ils veulent avoir la réchaud il
annonce la gestion des ressources qui
sont essentiels aux gains communs donc
un moyen de l'emprunt que vous êtes en
retard là dessus vous partagez j'entends
débat démocratique très bien parce que
moi je veux plus de démocratie pour les
dijonnais c'est à dire que je demanderai
aux autres jeunes et d'être acteur de la
vie locale de leur ville c'est faire des
référendums locaux sur plusieurs sujets
par exemple je leur ai fait sur la
semaine de quatre jours
pour moi c'est aux parents d'élèves et
aux professeurs de choisir c'est pas
forcément à des élus déconnecté de
choisir pour eux je refais aussi sur un
autre sujet important
la cité internationale de la gastronomie
et du vin il ya eu beaucoup de recours
qui a retardé tout ça pour moi la
meilleure décision à prendre
aurait était d'interroger les dijonnais
de les écouter et ensuite de suivre leur
choix on va terminer avant la démocratie
sur l'environnement
qu'on a on a n'a pas abordé le vélo et
la sécurisation des pistes cyclables
il ya des choses qui ont été faites
c'est indéniable sur le vélo le problème
c'est que depuis on n'a pas assez
investi et pas assez investis par an sur
la mise en place de vraies liane
finalement puisqu'on l'utilisent pour
les bus devraient liane de vélo et donc
la liste dijon l'avenir ensemble
s'engage quant à elles à mettre en place
comme les villes du nord 26 euros
l'équivalent de 26 euros par habitant
c'est environ 7 millions d'euros par an
d'investissements avec ça on va refaire
aussi la voirie et les trottoirs plus
d'argent sur les pistes audio
oui tout à fait pour les sécuriser parce
que il faut sortir du schéma où vous
allez faire du vélo tourisme pour aléas
du vélo du point a au point b le plus
efficace possible et ce faisant vous
pouvez à la fois refaire les voiries à
la fois être plus inclusif parce que
pour nos seniors sermet du mobilier
urbain pour les personnes handicapées
c'est revoir les trottoirs qui ne vont
pas et donc c'est aussi un vrai plan un
peu comme l'a été d'ailleurs pour le
tram
une manière de restructurer la ville de
lar végétalisée aussi en même temps donc
c'est un vrai plan global
il ya eu une expression lancée mais vous
pourrez reprendre le super eagle madame
c'était transport gratuit quelque chose
qui traverse un peu ces élections
municipales dans beaucoup de villes sur
les déplacements longs mois déjà sur
l'urbanisme pour en terminer cieux ya
effectivement un point extrêmement
important dans la transition écologique
on n'a pas abordé là c'est vraiment il
faut vraiment mettre en place un grand
plan de rénovation énergétique du bâti
ancien effectivement que soient publics
ou privés des copropriétés dégradées
notamment pourquoi parce que c'est
encore une fois ses limites et donc la
meilleure énergie c'est celle qu'on
n'utilise pas et là encore donc c'est
permettre ces moines charge pour les
habitants c'est moins d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et ceux de l'emploi
local et non localisables avec
effectivement aussi toute une filière à
monter sur les matières yeux sur ces sur
les déplacements sur les transports
effectivement le plan vélo donc nous
nous souhaitons vraiment un grand plan
vélo donc 7 millions dur on est tous
d'accord puisque en fait c'est pas nous
qui l'avons rencontré en tout cas moi
qui fais du vélo tous les jours c'est
vrai qu'il faut absolument que nous
puissions voilà c'est vrai je rencontre
régulièrement vélo voilà donc du coup
très ce que vous sentez en sécurité
objectivement actuellement on peut faire
du vélo à dijon ça reste très compliqué
il faut être très mais très très sûr de
soi donc effectivement il est impératif
maintenant d'avoir un grand plan vélo
avec des voix des autoroutes à vélo
comme on appelle effectivement dans les
pays du nord des voies sécurisées il
faut aussi mettre au maximum dans la
ville des zones à circulation 30 parce
que ça apaise ça permet aussi voilà que
chacun circulent sur parce
qu'effectivement et faire respecter
effectivement mais là on a les moyens
quand on se fait on peut et donc là
effectivement ce qui est intéressant
c'est que nous pouvons mettre donc plus
que les gens qui veulent faire du vélo
ils sont très nombreux je rappelle aussi
que le prix d'une voiture l'accès moyen
de l'eau mais on est en nous reste deux
minutes de façon non mais c'est
important quand même parce que ça si
c'est la qualité de la circulation
et puis le quotient effectivement c'est
développer encore encore mieux a fait 68
morts d'emmanuel bichot nous reste
minutes 30 avant mon départ de région je
voudrais évoquer un sujet sur la
circulation
c'est le aujourd'hui le problème
d'encombrement sur la lino et sur la
rocade
en fait ce problème il est doublement
pénalisante
il est pénalisant pour le pour
l'activité le dynamisme de la métropole
parce que les déplacements se font
difficilement l'accès aux eaux de
l'activité économique se fait
difficilement il est pénalisant
également pour l'environnement puisque
on a effectivement une augmentation des
rejets de gaz à effet de serre liées aux
déplacements
donc nous souhaitons nous investir très
rapidement sur la réorganisation des
ronds-points de valmy d'avis et de la
jonction avec l'arc à auxonne pas
premières une manière de manière de
manière à décongestionner les
embouteillages sur la livre baissait les
appeaux investirait à refaire l'église
saint-philibert transformer le parc
d'exposition est donc en deux ans la
ville un bail est avec vous ça ça oui
vous savez monsieur le maire sortant
d'un capacité d'investissement de la
commune de plus 30 millions d'euros par
an la capacité d'investissement de la
métropole de 60 millions d'euros par an
donc et les ronds-points jeu ça peu près
combien ça coûte parce que j'étais vice
présidents de conseils généraux
quand on a fait les les
l'échangeur du zénith et bien et bien
voilà et bien c'est à la fin de set et
cherche que je dois vous dire qu'on va
avant d'attaquer les conclusions va
écouter les trois autres têtes de liste
de ce scrutin à dijon bruno louy qui
mène une liste écologiste rester là
quand même si alexis agir pour la liste
d'avocats qui protestent contre la
réforme des retraites est claire rocher
pour lutte ouvrière on les écoute tout
de suite nous considérons que l'écologie
politique ne doit plus être simplement
une question environnementale dans un
projet plutôt axé compétitivité
attractivité béton minéralité notre
programme va va avoir trois buts le
premier c'est d'améliorer la qualité de
vie des citoyens d'agir également pour
la planète et permettre à dijon de
s'adapter aux futurs changements
climatiques
donc pour ça on a ça ça passe par par
nos cent douze propositions parmi
lesquelles les plus importantes sur la
végétalisation dans les quartiers plutôt
qu'au centre ville par les citoyens pour
les citoyens par la gratuité des
transports en commun parce que nous
voulons réduire la place de la voiture
en ville ça représente aujourd'hui 30 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
nous souhaitons également créé un outil
foncier de maraîchage urbain pour avoir
enfin au bout de 19 ans du bio local
dans les cantines je m'adresse aux
travailleurs aux chômeurs aux retraités
des classes populaires
nos intérêts vitaux avoir un salaire
avoir un emploi pouvoir se soigner sont
attaqués de toutes parts les grands de
ce monde sont aux prises avec une crise
de leurs économies qui menace de
s'effondrer comme un château de cartes
et leur solution c'est de la faire payer
aux classes populaires et tout ce qu'ont
subies dans nos vies c'est cette guerre
sociale qui est orchestrée par les
classes riches notre camp le camp des
travailleurs il a commencé à relever la
tête et il est important qu'ils se
renforcent que les élections municipales
soit une occasion de le faire voter pour
la liste lutte ouvrière faire entendre
le camp des travailleurs ça sera
l'occasion d'affirmer qu'il ya un
courant à dijon de travailleurs
conscients qu'ils ne se résignent pas et
qui sait qu'il faudra tôt ou tard
s'affronter à la bourgeoisie pour
l'empêcher de nuire
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait une
grosse difficultés sur la réforme des
retraites
notamment chez les avocats et on a voulu
par cette liste ouvrir une sorte de
canal démocratique qui permettrait aux
gens en général parce que c'est pas que
les avocats à un moment et aux dijonnais
donc de dire stop
on veut être écouté on veut être entendu
et ça fait des mois que le gouvernement
est sourd malgré les syndicats la rue
l'opposition est donc à un moment on se
dit mais à quel moment on va pouvoir
être entendue donc l'idée c'est qu'on
glisse le bulletin nous ne battrons pas
en retraite dans l'urne et là on fait
entendre notre voix et on explique qu'on
existe et qu'on doit être entendu c'est
un peu une rupture du contrat social
allez il est temps de conclure dans un
ordre que nous avons tirés au sort avant
l'émission et on commence par vous
stéphanie oui donc ces élections
municipales sont très importantes
il nous reste quelques années pour agir
en changeant nos modes de vie nos modes
de consommation et pour permettre à
chacun de reprendre le contrôle de sa
vie avec mon équipe à vos côtés nous
travaillerons pour faire de dijon une
ville unie est engagée contre toutes les
inégalités environnementales et sociales
une cité profondément accueillante et
solidaire une vie où chacun puisse se
loger décemment se nourrir sainement
100% bio dans les cantines notamment
travailler étudier se cultiver ils
vivent en toute tranquillité une vie
d'écologie dont vous habitants seraient
les acteurs de cette transformation
quel que soit votre statut entrepreneurs
salariés du public du privé étudiants
inactif en recherche d'emploi retraités
pour qu'ensemble nous puissions faire
vraiment de dijon une ville capable de
s'adapter et de répondre aux enjeux à la
fois climatique de biodiversité tout en
étant solidaire pour ne laisser personne
sur le bord de la route une vie c'est le
bon échelon pour agir localement tous
ensemble et contribuer à notre niveau a
donné une planète vivable pour les
générations à venir pour cela le 15 mars
nous veut critique pour dijon c'est le
vote dijon écologie vous avez les gens
auraient passé
stéphanie modde merci mme votre
conclusion maintenant arnaud granata
c'est à vous les amis dijon en commun
est un collectif de citoyens de
militants associatifs syndicaux et
politiques
il s'engage à répondre aux urgences de
notre temps d'urgence démocratique de
solidarité et écologique urgence
démocratique en permettant l'implication
citoyenne dans les grandes décisions
al'inverse du règne de l'opacité
actuelle urgence de solidarité dans la
lutte contre la précarité pour le
partage de la richesse et la
réappropriation de nos services publics
al'inverse des privatisations à tout-va
de l'équipe sortante aux urgences
écologiques pour préparer dijon
affronter le défi climatique grâce à la
mise en place de transports gratuits et
le développement du vélo nous l'avons
dit depuis 20 ans le ps europe ecologie
les verts le modem cogère dijon ils sont
responsables de ce bilan le élevé les
verts ont choisi de présenter salies
leur liste sans quitter l'équipe de
françois rebsamen ancien ministre de
françois hollande en gardant leurs
adjoints et leurs indemnités ils sont
une fausse opposition mes amis la clarté
impose des choix
nous l'avons fait celui de construire
avec vous l'alternative écologique
solidaire et citoyenne et les 15 et 22
mars votez pour vous votez pour dijon en
commun merci damien quant à cheikh
dijonnaise cher dijonnais nous sommes
dans la dernière ligne droite de cette
élection municipale
il nous reste quatre jours pour
mobiliser le maximum d'électeurs quatre
jours pour convaincre le maximum de
personnes autour de vous de me faire
confiance
faire rentrer des élus rassemblement
national au conseil municipal de dijon
c'est l'assurance d'être défendu pendant
six ans mes grands thèmes de campagne
vous les connaissez la proximité car
c'est avec vous que je veux faire la
ville de demain la sécurité et la
qualité de vie pour tous et par tous
coupables autour de cette table ils le
sont tous ils ont trahi et montrer à
leurs électeurs par compromissions et
intérêts politiques voter pour l'un de
ses candidats c'est voter emmanuel
macron je suis le seul candidat 100
marcheurs sur ma liste
alors dimanche je vous propose un autre
choix celui d'un candidat enracinée et
fier de représenter le rassemblement
national à dijon les 15 et 22 mars votez
damien quentin je compte sur vous merci
damien cantat on passe avoue emmanuel
bichot une minute de conclusion oui
dimanche le choix sera entre le mandat
de trop ou le renouvellement et moi je
propose aux lieux aux électeurs du jeune
et de changer l'équipe de changer de
pratiques de
cette politique nous voulons stopper la
bétonisation du maire sortant et de ses
adjoints europe ecologie les verts
c'est l'enjeu majeur de cette élection
nous voulons nous rénover les rues et
les trottoirs et assurer leur propreté
nous voulons doubler le nombre de
policiers municipaux pour protéger les
dix jeunes et de jour comme de nuit
nous voulons baisser les impôts locaux
ainsi que les tarifs publics en
réalisant des économies sur les dépenses
inutiles
nous voulons développer notre ville avec
les entreprises avec les formations avec
le tourisme avec notre patrimoine
exceptionnel et nous voulons faire une
démocratie locale plus vivante plus
transparente plus l écoute des dijonnais
de tous âges que nous voulons consultés
et que nous voulons associer aux
décisions
je consacrerai toute mon énergie à ce
projet à plein temps et durant toute la
durée du mandat
je votais pour la seule liste qui peut
réaliser ce changement voté pour la
liste de large rassemblement à agir pour
dijon merci mesdames et messieurs une
ville plus verte une ville plus sûre une
ville plus simple à vivre au quotidien
c'est ça remettre l'humain au coeur de
la ville pour ça il faut plus de
collaboration avec les citoyens avec les
associations avec les entreprises avec
les collectivités dole bonne le
département pour cela il faut aussi plus
de transparence fini l'opacité sur les
contrats il faut également une lutte
contre toutes formes de clientélisme
c'est le rebond de la confiance
celui qu'il faut ça ça demande un
changement de pratique et pour un
changement de pratique il faut un
renouvellement des personnes c'est ce
que je vous propose de voter le 15 mars
avec la liste dijon l'avenir ensemble
une liste de grands rassemblements au
centre parce que c'est au centre que 10
juin toujours des guerres et gagnante
et c'est au centre que je veux gagner
avec vous merci sylvain comparot on
termine avec vos françois rebsamen et
minutes pour conclure cher dijonnaise
cher dijonnais dimanche prochain vous
allez voter pour désigner celui ou celle
qui dirigera notre ville pendant six ans
je voudrais vous dire pour en être le
maire aujourd'hui que pour être maire il
faut d'abord aimer dijon et tous ses
habitants quelles que soient leurs
conditions sociales et leur origine
dijon c'est capital l'aller
que je conduis ce n'est pas la liste de
la démagogie électorale c'est la liste
des solutions tout ce que nous proposons
est finançable sans augmentation des
impôts pour les six prochaines années
dijon c'est capital ce n'est pas la
liste qui attise les peurs c'est la
liste du coeur dijon c'est capital ce
n'est pas une liste du rejet de l'autre
c'est la liste qui porta laïcité la
valeur qui nous rassemble et qui fait de
dijon une ville à vivre pour tous dijon
c'est capital c'est une liste composée
d' humaniste de progressis d'européens
dans dijon a besoin pour poursuivre sur
la voie du progrès économique écologique
et la solidarité
aussi dès le premier tour dimanche
prochain ne vous trompez pas voter pour
votre maire françois rebsamen et pour la
liste dijon c'est capital merci françois
rebsamen rappelons que l'ordre de ces
conclusions avaient été tirés au sort
avant l'émission nous voilà au terme de
ce débat merci à tous les six d'être
venu jouer le jeu parfois compliqué
d'expression démocratique
merci stéphane lissner si lilian c'est
un plaisir